- I loved what y'all were
talking about in the video too.
I think that about a song.
If you can't break it down
with just a piano or just a guitar,
then it's not a great song.
You're the most magical songwriter.
- And when we've worked together,
I mean it's always like,
can we make this work without
all the bells and whistles?
And if you can,
then you can put all that stuff on it
and the song really works.
- But, if you can't,
it's not really what it's supposed to be.
- Exactly, exactly.
- I agree.
We do non-kid stuff too though y'all.
We've lost a lot, I've lost a lot,
of money in Vegas with you.
But, we won a lot one time!
- I know.
- And we've done duets.
- But, that one time when we won,
we have been trying...
- The one time we won,
we won...
- But, it was like...
- What game are you playing?
Craps?
- We were playing, well
we played, 3-card poker,
we played slots...
- Slots.
- Remember at that 3-card poker table?
Where that person came up to you and said
the dealer was like,
oh I love So Small so much
it's my favorite song.
- Yeah, Carrie Underwood.
I was like, I'm not Carrie Underwood.
Yeah.
(laughs)
- I mean, literally,
I'm so complimented by it
because she's like super hot and thin
so I'm like, maybe I'll just rock it.
Maybe I'll just be like, yes, thank you.
- Well, of course, I'm behind her going,
hey dumb ass, that's Kelly Clarkson.
(laughs)
- Like, huge star!
- I loved it though.
I loved it.
Now, we also karaoke as well.
We have karaoked quite a bit.
- I have to tell the
karaoke story about you.
- Okay, is it daytime appropriate?
- It is, well I mean, look.
I don't know for sure
if anything we've done
is daytime appropriate.
So, we would go karaokeing in Nashville,
which I know you have an
actual connection with.
- Yes.
- They should come karaokeing sometime.
- Okay.
- But, this woman,
she's up there in a wig.
She wears this crazy Mohawk wig.
- I love wigs.
- And she's singing.
I think you were singing
Ice Ice Baby in my mind.
- Maybe with Donovan then.
- Yeah, probably.
- Yeah, that's her song, that's her go-to.
- And, yeah, with Ashley Donovan
and this woman goes,
that girl reminds me so
much of Kelly Clarkson.
I mean, she's no Kelly Clarkson.
(laughs)
But, she reminds me of her.
It was so fun.
- Well, I was probably d-runk,
so I probably wasn't.
- No, that was awesome.
- It is the most fun place
to go karaokeing though.
All the honky tonks,
there's bars right down there.
- Well then everybody can really sing.
- I know, but it's good
when the bad ones get up.
- I know, right?
- Yeah, those are the fun ones.
- Right, that's like
when I get up and sing.
- Yeah, it's like Rudy.
You're like, you can do it!
- Do it Rudy!
(laughs)
- So, how is your mom?
I saw her at that Dallas show.
I didn't know this,
but I read your pre-interview.
I didn't know that you told your mom,
whatever you do, don't
mention American Idol.
Which, I don't know why
you would have done that.
I don't care.
But, it was the first
thing she said to me!
- So, I have this little show.
I'm doing this songwriter show.
I mean, this is 2006?
- This is a long time ago.
- I mean, that's a long time ago.
- Yeah.
- And Kelly was going to come.
Now, this is a small room of people
and my mom was like,
I just want to meet Kelly.
And I said, look,
I'm going to introduce you to Kelly.
I don't even really know her that well,
but I do know that all she ever
hears about is American Idol
so just don't mention that.
- Which I didn't care.
- I know, but I didn't know you
and my mom said,
oh I would never do that.
Okay, so then I say,
mom this is Kelly, and she goes,
we voted for you every week.
(laughs)
It was the first thing.
(applause)
- That's what moms are for.
- That's exactly right.
- To embarrass the heck out of you.
- I love it. I love it.